Nhà đại anh bị bí xí, ngày Mỹ bài thêm 1 tuyên bố sản sản đối đầu pháp liy,
nếu tổng thủ Mỹ đô năng trăm khởi két,
khẳng định không có cơ sở pháp liy nào cho các cảo bộ phía bàng liên quan tử video,
bài phát biểu bị trình sửa của ông Trump.
Chúng tịch bí bí xí, xam, xa, nhìn mạnh,
đại sẽ không thay đổi lập trường và có trình nhận bảo vệ người đằng phía truyền hình.
Chúng đỏ tổng thủ Mỹ đô năng trăm trò biết,
đang xem xét két đại bí bí xí tại bàng Freuda,
nơi ông của anh hợp chiếc để đợi bụi thường từ một đế năm tỷ đồ.
Ông cáu vô bí bí xí đã chíu một phim tài liệu trong đỏ cách gái mạnh phát biểu của ông,
đạo cảm giác rằng ông đang kêu hỏi vào lực trong vụ đồ képito năm hành hình của Trump.
Bí bí xí đã gửi thử xí lỗi tự nhà trắng sau đó,
nhưng nhà đại của anh vẫn mắt bỏ cáu bụi phía bàng.
Châu rằng đoàn phía em zombie thuba thực hiện và chưa tựng đô phát tại Mỹ,
đại dự két lập lộn rằng cự chỉ bàng Freuda vôn không thể xem truy trình này,
ra đó không thể của tiết hại quy tình như phía ông Trump đến bố.
Bố viên cũng là bùng lên là sống truy trách trách về quy trình biệt tập lộn dông.
Khiến tổng rằng đốc BBC team David cũng lạnh đạo mạng tình trước đế Bora Turnest,
phải từ trước.
Theo các chuyên gia pháp liệu em hiểu bình đề,
tổng thủ đồ đang trăm dự định nói mức bối thường lớn để gái áp lực và thế hiệp xức giận dưới.
Nhưng ở Mỹ, nơi quyền tự dọn ngon lợn được khiến pháp bảo vệ đặc biệt,
két tội phía bàng thường rất khó thắng.
Đặc biệt, nối với các nhân vật công chúng như Trump thống.